[Music]  is Sir Elton John singing at the Royal  Wedding Elton just moved the dates for  two of his Vegas concerts which just so  happens to be the weekend of May 19th  when area Megan will say their I Do's a  rep for the Colosseum at Caesars Palace  called the move quote a scheduling  conflict and meet the new Megan  look-alike actress / Risa Fitz Henley  will play Markel in the upcoming  Lifetime movie hey folks we're here for  day one of Harry and Megan royal romance  and I'm heading into my trailer for the  first time looking forward to sharing  everything with you she also posted this  pic of her harry actor Murray Fraser  they appear to be doing a scene in bed  and did Megan almost work on the Whitney  Williams Show according to the talk-show  host she did the future royal appeared  on the remake of 9:02 and oh and a shows  AnnaLynne McCord sat down with Wendy  you